well major news to start the day really
pretty big news here in Robert molars
Trump Russia investigation because we
learned yesterday that former Trump
chief strategist Steve Bannon of
Breitbart Fame of chief propagandist
Fame of being one of trumps clearly
closest inner-circle advisors Fame was
not only subpoenaed by Robert molars
Russia investigation he showed up to a
house panel which also requested his
presence and refused to answer a ton of
questions that he was asked this
initially started last week last week
Steven Bannon was subpoenaed notified of
this subpoena from the robert muller
investigation then he testified
yesterday
before a House panel so let's first stop
and talk about the grand jury piece with
Robert molars investigation if you
testify before a grand jury and we've
gone through this routine before if a
grand jury exists it's because Robert
Muller believes that crimes may have
been committed and the point of the
grand jury is to figure out whether
particular charges should be brought
based on the evidence that exists and on
the testimony of grand jury witnesses so
that alone is a major revelation because
it's the first time that at least we're
aware of that Robert Muller is using a
grand jury to subpoena someone from
Trump's inner circle to get information
from them yesterday we also learned
about this additional subpoena that
exists from the house panel and Steven
Bannon testified there yesterday and
yesterday there were ten hours of
questions to Stephen Bannen behind
closed doors with the House Intelligence
Committee reports are that it became
significantly argumentative would be one
way to say it
and that Bannon said over and over again
that he simply couldn't answer many of
the questions or that he wouldn't answer
many of the questions because of again
executive privilege and of course there
are immediately legal questions about
that because executive privilege is not
necessarily bannon's to assert but
there's legal disagreement about that so
I don't want to focus on that too too
much but what this tells us about the
nature of the questions from the House
Intelligence panel is that they're
digging very deep very deeply into
direct Trump material and right after
these ten hours of questioning yesterday
Democrats on the committee came out and
said we believe that the White House
actually got to Steve Bannon to prevent
him from top talking about the topics
that we were asking him and that we
brought up the good news if you're the
Trump administration is that Bannon was
nothing more than a coffee boy basically
an intern with no knowledge or access to
anything important right otherwise this
might really be bad and a concern for
Trump and we've seen that attempt to
frame everybody every single person who
has either been indicted or become the
focus of this investigation or has since
been fired or resigned they really had
minor roles Michael Flynn well yeah I
mean he was national security adviser
but only for a few weeks and then he was
forced to resign Sean Spicer
yeah from day one as press secretary he
went out and told lie after lie after
lie
but listen it's just the press secretary
after all Papadopoulos Trump barely even
knew this guy and of course the picture
came out of him at a meeting and then
Paul Manafort he was like a nobody he
was tangentially involved with the
campaign but that being said I do get
the sense that he's not directly
implicated in the Russia scandal he did
join the Trump campaign in August of
2016 the last few months but I also get
the sense that if things Russia were
being discussed in a meeting say he
wouldn't get up and leave I think you
would want to hear that you see details
what you're saying is actually part of
the analysis that some legal experts are
putting out there which is that you
don't subpoena to a grand jury the
target of an investigation so what we
can we can read a lot into this right we
can read into this that these are
signals from molar that Bannon is going
to have to tell the truth and come clean
because you will go to jail or at least
risk going to jail if you lie to the FBI
or to investigators but the
a signal that comes from this relates to
what Pat just said which is that if
Bannon were a target of this
investigation he would not be subpoenaed
to testify before a grand jury in this
way and that that's indicative as the
legal experts are saying that Bannon is
not a target of this investigation and
that doesn't surprise me because you've
said before that you actually don't
think Bannon was wrapped up in this rush
of stuff I generally so I I generally
have no reason to believe so either so
that that is definitely something that
we can glean for this if you're Bannon
what do you do right on the one hand I
guess that you joined up with Trump
maybe because you believed in his
potential to change politics and the US
for the better or something maybe Bannon
just joined up for personal gain
greed self aggrandizement we don't know
but we know he's had a pseudo
falling-out with Trump Trump says Bannon
lost his mind when he left the White
House kind of convenient timing right
because now Steve Bannon will have the
opportunity to truly screw Trump over
depending on what he knows and this
would be like the epic power alpha move
for Bannon right Trump slams Bannon
publicly and then Bannon goes to the
grand jury comes clean on everything and
he can actually say listen this is a
grand jury I'm not gonna perjure myself
and lie but we know Trump does expect
his loyal subservient staffers to do
that we know that Michael Flynn was
involved in lies Jeff Sessions as his
Attorney General has been a lie machine
I actually think Trump does expect and
demand that these people lied to cover
him yeah or Bannon could even flip on
Kushner - you remember Bannon and
Kushner had that feud that went on for
months yeah in the White House I mean
Kushner didn't like Bannon because of
the Muslim ban ban didn't like Kushner
because he's a Jew I guess globalist was
that what I thought it was more just
that he not everything he had no
business being involved which by the way
Bannon was right that Kushner had no
business being involved in an
administration but neither does Bannon
that's the funny thing a last thought on
this every time there's a big step
forward in the Trump Russia
investigation an indictment a Gil
deeply blockbuster documents you get
more people saying things like you're
still paying attention to this Russian
nonsense there's nothing there when you
hear that next time and if you spend 30
seconds on YouTube today or on the
internet on internet news websites
you'll see it step back for a second and
just think of the trajectory of this
entire thing for the last 12 to 18
months first it was there's never going
to be an investigation
well commis looking into it he's not
gonna find anything
well commis been fired by Trump to stop
the investigation
Moeller has been appointed special
prosecutor nothing will come of that
well then you've got the man afford
indictment and the Papadopoulos
indictment well that's as far as it's
going to go and it has nothing to do
with anything anybody did while working
for Trump well then he had the Michael
Flynn indictment who was Trump's
national security advisor listen he was
a small player and the whole thing it's
completely meaningless the investigation
is going to be done by Christmas 2017 or
New Year's Day 2018 and now and the
epitome of the inner circle member for
the Trump team Steve Bannon is
subpoenaed still nothing to see here
clearly it's going nowhere right ignore
those people allow this thing to run its
course and then there will be plenty of
time to look back and Monday Morning
Quarterback everything that happened the
video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership